[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAUREN LONG: Good afternoon.
My name is Lauren.
I'm here with Hiranya.
We are two engineers on the
Firebase team at Google,
and today we're excited
to share with you how
you can integrate Firebase into
your existing infrastructure.
So to start, I want to introduce
you to Firebase in case
you haven't used it already.
Firebase is Google's app
development platform.
We make it really easy to
build and ship your apps fast.
We support a number of platforms
like Android, iOS, web,
and games, and we are built on
top of Google Cloud Platform
so you get all the benefits
of the global scalability
of Google Cloud Platform.
These are the products
that Firebase offers.
We offer things to help
you build your apps better
and faster, improve your apps'
quality by monitoring them,
and grow your apps' audience by
being able to analyze, predict,
and send targeted messages.
There are a few products
we're using today in our talk,
so I'll give you a brief
introduction to each of them.
The first one is
Firebase Authentication.
This is our solution for
managing users within your app.
There are a number
of OAuth providers
we support like Google,
Facebook, GitHub.
And perhaps most important
for our presentation
today, we also support
custom authentication,
where we can integrate into
your existing user store.
Next, we have a
database solution
called Cloud Firestore.
This is one of the two database
solutions that Firebase offers.
And Cloud Firestore is a
document-based database
that's really great for
real-time applications.
So if you're
building an app where
you want the page to change
whenever the underlying
data changes without the user
having to refresh the page,
this is a great
solution for you.
Now you might be
thinking, how do I
make sure that only
certain users have access
to the database, and they
only have access to the parts
that they should be
granted access into?
That's where security
rules comes in,
and that's when we tie together
Firebase Authentication
with a database to
allow fine-grain access
control for your apps' users.
Thirdly, we have Cloud
Functions for Firebase, which
is our serverless solution.
So you might have heard
about Google Cloud Functions
during this conference.
This is built directly
on top of Google Cloud
Functions with a set of
Firebase specific tooling.
And Cloud Functions allows you
to respond to different events
happening in your app.
For example, an
Auth trigger allows
you to listen to when
a new user signed in.
A Firestore trigger
allows you listen
to when data has been saved.
Or you can listen to an
Analytics Conversion event
to know when someone
does something
like complete a purchase.
We support a number of
other [INAUDIBLE] providers
like Pub Sub,
other GCP triggers,
and other Firebase triggers.
Now, you might be
thinking, that sounds great
but I'm working with legacy
systems, user stores that
already have existing users,
and other databases that
fit my company's needs.
How do I integrate
those with Firebase?
Or maybe I have ML models
or other cloud services,
admin dashboards, tools
that I want to be building.
So apps don't
exist in isolation.
Yours don't.
Mine doesn't either.
So how do you integrate
Firebase in a seamless way
with your existing
infrastructure and back end
systems?
HIRANYA JAYATHILAKA: Firebase
solves many problems for you.
It's a very large and
versatile platform.
But as Lauren pointed
out, Firebase, or rather
mobile apps, also often
have external integration
requirements.
Firebase acknowledges
this fact and strives
to make it a little easier for
you to integrate your existing
systems with Firebase.
To that end, we
provide a set of SDKs
called Admin SDKs which you can
extend your existing systems so
they [INAUDIBLE] and share data
with the Firebase platform.
Alternatively, you can
use [INAUDIBLE] APIs
that we provide so your
systems can directly talk
to Firebase or [INAUDIBLE].
The basic idea here
is that Firebase
helps you solve many problems
related to app development.
But if you ever want to
go beyond the boundaries
of the Firebase platform and
bring in your own systems
and own data and APIs
into the architecture,
Firebase supports that too.
So let's talk about these
different integration options
starting with the Admin SDK.
Many Firebase developers,
if you've ever
written any apps with
Firebase, then you
should already be
familiar with our client
SDKs available for platforms
like Android, iOS, web,
and Unity.
Admin SDKs are
different from them
in the sense they are not
designed to be integrated,
or they're not designed
to be directly used,
by the end users of your app.
In other words, you
would never deploy
an Admin SDK on your end users
mobile device or their web
browser.
Instead, they are meant to be
used to build [? callback ?]
[? in ?] services and
administrative tools
for your apps.
Because of this, you will
only deploy admin SDKs
in the service that you or your
organization owns and controls.
Alternatively, you
can deploy them
in managed cloud environments
like Google Cloud Functions
or App Engine, where you,
as the app developer,
has control over the code.
Admin SDKs are available in
five server side programming
languages as of today, and
we will look at some of them
during the upcoming demos.
So speaking of
demos, pretty much
all the demos that we are
going to look at today
are based on a fun,
little movie rating app
that we built called FireFlicks.
I think it's very fitting
since we are literally
sitting in a movie theater.
So let's go [? to our ?]
demo machine
and see what this looks like.
It's built using our JavaScript
SDK and the Vue framework.
If you go to this interface,
you will see some example movies
and some rating data.
All that information is stored
in Google Cloud Firestore.
We also support several
authentication schemes
including Google Sign in.
All of that is made
possible by Firebase Auth,
and this live version
of the app is coming
to you via Firebase hosting.
Today you can use this interface
to add some movie reviews
or add them to a personal
collection for easier look up.
So this looks fairly
complete at this point,
but we are not quite done.
In fact, throughout the rest
of the course of this talk,
we are going to implement
several new use cases that
will require us to
integrate what we have today
with a bunch of
external systems.
So let's go back to the slides.
Some other use cases we
are going to implement.
First, we want to be able
to invite selected users
to join the FireFlicks
platform and become
moderators of the community.
We want to be able to send
out some emails containing
invitation codes to
these selected users,
and they should be able
to log in to FireFlicks
using those invitation codes.
And when they do they
should automatically
gain elevated
privileges in the app.
Then we would want to implement
some new backend services
to extend the
capabilities of our app,
but we would also
want to make sure
that only specific
users can actually
consume these external APIs.
FireFlicks also
supports self sign up,
so you can just go to
a website and self sign
up using an email
address and a password.
For such users,
we would also want
to run some kind of
email verification flow.
So they should get a link
they can click and confirm
their email, and we
would want to implement
that using some kind of a third
party email delivery service--
something like
SendGrid, for example.
And finally, we want to keep
track of the movie [INAUDIBLE]
posted by the users.
We want to encourage users
to post, but at the same time
we want to prevent them
from potentially spamming
the system with too many posts.
So let's go through these
use cases one by one
and see how they
are implemented.
Let's begin with our requirement
for inviting selected users
to be moderators.
We would want to
obviously pre-provision
these user accounts
and grant them
moderator role ahead of time.
Then we would want to
be able to send them
out some invitation codes.
But first, let's talk
about the idea of roles
and how it's managed in
a platform like Firebase.
In FireFlicks,
what we really want
is the ability to differentiate
between two classes of users--
let's say regular
users and moderators.
Regular users can just sign up.
They can read most of
the data on the app
and they can post reviews.
[? Moderators, ?] on the other
hand, are by invitation only.
They have read
access to everything,
can do pretty much everything
a regular user can,
but they also have access to
certain privileged capabilities
like adding new movies.
In order to support
and enforce rules
correctly in an app
such as FireFlicks,
we should be able to
identify the user's role
both in the client code and
also in the backend services
the client app depends on.
One of the easiest ways to
do this in Firebase ecosystem
is by using a technique
called custom claims.
It's built right into
the Firebase Auth flow,
so let's spend a
minute on figuring out
how that actually works.
When a Firebase app kicks
off the sign-in flow,
it sends the user's login
credentials to Firebase Auth.
Firebase Auth validates them,
and if everything looks good
sends back an ID token
refresh token pair.
At this point, the
app is signed in
and it can use the ID token
to call any Firebase back end
services-- services
like Firestore.
The ID token is short lived.
It expires every
hour, at which point
the app can use the refresh
token to gain a new ID
token for the next hour.
If you build an app using
one from our client SDKs
it handles this
entire flow for you,
so you don't have to
do anything really.
It even takes care of
automatic refreshing
of the ID token periodically.
The ID token itself is just
a JWT, or a JSON Web Token,
that contains some metadata
about the user encoded into it.
There's a header, a body, and
it is signed by Firebase Auth
so it cannot really be forged.
Now what custom claims
gives us is the ability
to add our own custom
metadata, such as roles,
into this [INAUDIBLE].
You can use the Admin SDK
to permanently associate
some custom claims
with a user account.
And then whenever that
user logs into our app,
Firebase Auth will automatically
include those custom claims
in the user's ID token.
And as you can see, once
we get the roles encoded
into the user's
ID token, then we
can validate those claims in
various components of our app
to implement access control.
For instance, we can
check for user's roles
but in our own backend
code using the Admin SDK.
There's also a way to inspect
claims via Firebase security
rules.
That enables you to
implement access control
in your Firestore,
Firebase Storage,
and Firebase Realtime
Database API calls.
We will see examples of all
these techniques shortly.
But for now, let's go
back to our original use
case of implementing a
user invitation flow.
Our invitation
flow should really
take care of three things.
It should create the
account in Firebase Auth
and grant it the
moderator role by setting
some custom [AUDIO OUT].
Then it should generate
an invitation code
for the new user and save in
some kind of a database or user
store.
This way when the user
eventually logs in we
have a way of verifying
their invitation code.
And finally, it should just
email out the invitation code
to the user.
Now there are several different
ways you can implement this.
You probably have a
user provisioning flow
in your organization.
You can bake this
into that or you
can build a new administrative
tool to handle this.
What we did was to
basically build out
a little Python script using
the Firebase Python Admin
SDK to handle this entire flow.
So let's go our demo and
see how it's implemented
and then see how
it actually works.
So I have a little Python
script called create_user.py,
and one of the first things
I do in this script is just
importing the Admin SDK and
some of its child modules.
And then I have
a function called
run_user_invitation_flow,
which takes the email address
of the target user and runs the
invitation flow for that user.
So the first thing we do is
just initializing the Admin SDK.
If you've written any code using
pretty much any Firebase SDK,
then the initialize app
API should ring some bells
in your head.
Once we have
initialized the SDK,
we can use the Auth API,
specifically the create_user
API, to create a new user
account in Firebase Auth.
This returns an object which
contains the unique user
ID that Firebase
Auth has assigned.
And we can use that
user ID and pass it
to the set custom user
claims API to set some custom
claims on the user account.
In this case, it's
just one claim
called moderator equals true.
And then we have some code here
to generate an invitation code
for the user.
It's just a random
string that we generate.
We store all this information
in a collection called Invites
in Cloud Firestore,
so we are basically
using Cloud Firestore as
our custom user database.
You can use any database
you like for this purpose.
And finally, we have
send_invitation_email helper
function, which sends out this
email using a SendGrid API
call.
So let's try this out and
see if it actually works.
So I'm going to run the
script locally on my machine,
and I'm going to
invite Lauren to become
moderator of FireFlicks.
So this creates the
moderator account,
grants the permissions,
and sends out the email.
At this point, we can actually
go to Firebase Console and just
search for user account.
Make sure it got created.
Yep, there's the
new user account.
Just created today minutes ago,
and if you go to our Firestore
Console we will also
see a new invitation
for laurenfirebase@gmail.com.
Let's go back to the demo.
The next step of this
use case is actually
making it possible
for a user to log
in using one of those invitation
codes that we just emailed out.
Now remember this is not
a standard authentication
mechanism.
This is just something
that we are inventing.
So since we invited
Lauren I'm going
to invite her back
here to demonstrate
how that part is implemented.
LAUREN LONG: Thanks, Hiranya.
So I've just been invited
with the Python script.
I should have gotten
an email with a code--
an email combination.
We will then, in our app, build
a custom authentication service
to verify that this code and
email combination is valid.
To do that we will be querying
our custom user store.
In this case, it's actually
just a Cloud Firestore database,
but this could be substituted
with any number of user stores
that would be suitable
for your application.
After it verifies
that code is valid,
it then uses the Firebase Admin
SDK to generate a custom token.
Send that back to
the client app.
The client app
will use it to log
in to the application with
Firebase Authentication.
So what's underpinning
this flow is custom token,
which is what's generated
by the Firebase Admin SDK.
This is what it might look like.
You'll see that it is
signed by a service account,
and the most important
information it contains
is the User ID, or
the UID for short.
And this UID is what will map
to the Firebase Authentication
user that gets created in
our project once I log in.
So to sign in with
a custom token,
it's done through
the client app.
And we provide a method in
each of our client's SDK's
for them to be able to sign in
to Firebase Auth with a custom
token.
And once the sign
in occurs, they
receive an ID token
in return, and this
is very similar to signing
in with another provider
like a Facebook or a
GitHub or a Gmail sign in.
So let's see how
that works in action.
So if we can switch
to the demo, please.
So here I've got my
email open, and I
see that I've just been
invited to join as a moderator.
So here I have a code which I
will copy without triggering
the definition.
Let's now try to sign in.
So I click on sign in with
code, with my email address,
and the code I just copied.
Click on Submit.
It then asks me if I want to
sync it with my Google sign in.
I don't want to do
that at the moment.
But as you can see, I
now have a new tab called
Moderator that just appeared.
So let's switch back
to the slides, please.
So let's review
what just happened.
I got invited.
I was emailed a code.
I then was able to sign in
to our custom authentication
service, and I'll show
you that code in a moment.
And that custom
authentication service
then verifies that code
with a custom user store.
It then generates a custom token
with the Firebase Admin SDK,
and the client app
receives that and signs
in to Firebase Authentication.
So if we can switch back
to the demo screen, please.
So our custom authentication
service is written in Go,
and in this case, we've
hosted on Google App Engine.
But it could easily be
hosted on your own server
or another cloud provider.
The method that's interesting
to us is called authenticate,
and it is a method that
receives a couple of parameters.
So we have the context
of the request that
was sent, the email
of the user that's
trying to sign in as
a moderator, the code
that they are using, and
this method is a method off
of an admin client.
So this is a client that we've
initialized with the Firebase
Admin SDK in Go.
We first query the user
store for this email and code
combination, and this user store
returns that user if it exists.
And if it doesn't,
we get an error back
and we throw that error.
If it does exist we then
use the Firebase Amman
client that we've already
initialized previously
with the Auth service
of the Admin client,
and we generate a custom
token with the user ID.
So we return this custom
token back to the client,
and that's how the client was
able to sign in and verify
that I was a moderator.
If we can switch back
to the slides, please.
So this is a great way
to integrate Firebase
with existing user
stores that you
might be using like Active
Directory or LDAP or something
custom.
HIRANYA JAYATHILAKA: Now that
we have integrated some users
and rules with our
app, the next step
would be to actually
go ahead and build out
some new APIs and new services
to integrate our app with.
But also, implement some
role-based access control
on top of those services.
Specifically, we
would want to make
sure that only signed in users--
that users who have signed
into our web app--
can access these APIs,
or only the signed in moderators
can access these APIs.
Now we already know that we can
identify an authenticated user
by looking at the ID.
Token we also know that
we can inspect the custom
claims in those ID
tokens to figure out
what roles they have.
So the easiest way to
implement access control
in your own backend code
is by just checking--
just decoding the ID token and
just checking what's in there.
We get the user or the
client to send the ID token
with every backend request.
We use the Admin
SDK to verify the ID
token or additionally
check roles,
and then if the check passes,
we can go ahead and perform
any of the privileged
operations the user wishes
to perform on the server.
So to demonstrate
this functionality,
we are going to build
a new service that
enables FireFlicks
users to tweet
using the official
FireFlicks Twitter handle.
But we want to make sure that
only authenticated moderators
are able to access
this endpoint.
We allow moderators to create
new movies in our database,
so hopefully they
can use this feature
to tweet about new additions.
So the way, this is
going to be implemented
is we are going to put our
backend logic for actually
tweeting using the Twitter
API in a backend server.
The user will call out to this
endpoint using the tweet that
needs to be published
along with the ID token,
and then we will verify it.
And if everything
looks good, we'll
call the Twitter API
on behalf of the user.
We implement this service in Go.
In fact, it's going to be a
simple addition to the same Go
application that Lauren
demonstrated earlier, so it's
running in Google App Engine.
A moderator can
call it from the app
and get the Twitter API
invoked through that.
So let's go to our demo
machine again and see
what that code looks like.
The function that gets
triggered in this flow
is called CheckAuth.
It receives the ID token of
the caller as an argument.
If you don't get
an ID tokens-- that
means if a request comes in
without a validated token--
we return an error immediately.
If not, we'll go ahead and
call the VerifyIDToken API
off the Admin SDK.
This performs a
series of checks,
and if everything
looks good, it actually
gives us a decoded
representation of the ID token.
And we can query that
decoded representation
to check if it actually has
the moderator claim in it.
If not, again, we
return an error.
Now we wired up our web
application in a way
so that all incoming requests
first hit this function.
And if it returns
an error [INAUDIBLE]
401 unauthorized error.
Otherwise this
code will actually
go and call the Twitter API.
So let's see how
this code actually
works by first sending a
couple of fake requests.
So this is the
[INAUDIBLE] App Engine
that we are going to call.
First, I'm going to call this
without any ID token error
at all.
I'm basically sending this
hello would post request.
So as we would expect,
we get an ID token
not specified error,
which is the error
message that we return when
there's no ID token available.
Alternatively, we can try to
send a bogus ID token header.
Firebase ID token is the custom
header that our web [INAUDIBLE]
programmed for.
But this is just a fake JWT.
It just looks like an ID
token, but it's really not.
So it fails to verify the token
signature, as you would expect.
So to get this check to pass
you have to actually call it
as a moderator [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to use this
new tweet function.
Tweet something.
It says tweet posted,
so hopefully we
can see it on the
Twitter right now.
There we go.
So let's go back to our slides.
Now we've been
telling you, you can
use the Admin SDK
to verify ID tokens,
but we haven't really told you
what happens under the hood.
The check performed by the Admin
SDK is actually quite strong.
It checks for a number
of things like it
has the correct signature, which
is by far the most important
thing, but it also
[? checks that ?] the token
is not expired.
[AUDIO OUT] that has to be
checked, and also things
like the token was indeed issued
against your Firebase project,
not coming from some random
other Firebase project.
And also, this is a
fairly fast operation.
It's not making any
RPC calls, so it
is OK to do this check for
every incoming request.
Now one thing this
API doesn't check for
is whether the ID token
is revoked or not.
Our Admin SDKs actually
have a revoke refresh token
[AUDIO OUT] to users
up to that point.
It's [AUDIO OUT].
Now if you want to check
if the ID token has
been revoked since
it was issued,
there's a separate API for that.
In Go it's called
VerifyIDTokenAndCheckRevoked,
but this actually does make
an API call or RPC call,
so you do have to take
that overhead into account.
The other way you can enforce
roles and authorization
in Firebase apps is by using
Firebase security rules.
Security rules are a
policy driven approach
to intercept API calls
made by your clients
to services like Firestore,
cloud storage, and Realtime
Database, and make sure that
they adhere to certain policies
that you've defined.
For example, we have this
Firestore security rule
in place, which is what
restricts the ability
to create [? new ?] [AUDIO OUT]
only the moderators.
So this rule applies to
our movies collection,
which is a collection
we actually
have in our Firestore database.
That's where all the movies are.
As you can see, we give
the right permission
to only [? users ?] who
contains the moderator
claim in their Auth token.
This [AUDIO OUT] from
being [INAUDIBLE] create
or [AUDIO OUT].
Moving on to our
next use case, which
is to be able to run an email
verification for our self
sign up users.
We need to [INAUDIBLE]
to basically send a user
some kind of a verification
link which they can
confirm their email address.
Now interestingly,
this is actually
something you can do
just in the client side
using our client SDKs.
Our client SDKs provide
a sendEmailVerification
[? API. ?] [? When ?]
[? you ?] call it,
[AUDIO OUT] email
verification flow for you.
However, the email
sent out by this API--
they use a pre-configured
set of email templates
and they also use a built-in
email delivery service.
But if you're a
large enterprise,
you probably would want
to customize the content
and layout of these emails
by including the company logo
and other branding information
in the emails that go out,
or you may have your own
email [AUDIO OUT] for things
which [? you ?] want to use.
So if you want that
kind of flexibility,
then you should consider
implementing this flow
as another back integration.
So how are we going to do it?
We are going to use Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
We are going to implement
[AUDIO OUT] every time a new
user signs up to
[? FireFlicks. ?] And inside
this function, we will
use [? the ?] Node.js SDK
to generate a email
[? verification ?] [AUDIO OUT],,
put it into a template
of our choosing,
and send out using a third-party
mail delivery service--
SendGrid in this case.
So let's go to our
demo machine and let's
look at what this Cloud
Function looks like.
Whoa.
Thank you.
So we have a Cloud Function
called sendEmailVerification.
As you can see,
this is implemented
using the Firebase
Functions SDK, which
is a set of extensions
that are developed on top
of Google Cloud Functions.
So we have onCreate
trigger type,
which gets triggered
every time a new user
signs up for our project.
This receives a
UserRecord object
that describes the
newly signed up user.
The first thing we do is
check whether this is actually
a password or a self sign
up user with a password.
Because you see, we have
several different ways
users can sign up to our
app-- through Google sign in
or it could be a
user that we manually
create using our Python script.
So we had to first
filter those out,
so we have a little
check for that here.
But if it is a
password user, then we
go ahead and call the
Admin SDK, specifically
the
generateEmailVerificationLink
API, which gives us a URL link.
Then we have the
sendEmail helper function,
which puts it into
our own template
and sends it out using SendGrid.
So I'm going to go
ahead and create
a new account on our website.
I'm just going to log out
of the existing session
and go ahead and
click on Sign Up.
I'm just going to
use the same email
address but with a suffix.
And just add a
password there, Submit,
and that will actually create
the account and log me in.
But as you can see, the
system recognizes that it's
an unverified user account.
Not that event alone should have
triggered our Cloud Function,
so we can go to the
Cloud Function's console
or the logs in our project.
Hopefully we'll see the
new event here, 1:47.
That's about a few seconds
ago, so the link is already
in route.
We can probably--
oh, here we go.
So we now have a
verified email link
sent out by our Cloud Function.
We can use this link to actually
verify our user account.
The system recognized me
as a verified user account
because I clicked on the link.
Let's go back to the slides.
So in addition to generating
email verification links,
our Admin SDKs also
have APIs for generating
password reset links and
links for email sign in.
You can use these
APIs to further flesh
out your user
management landscape
and truly integrate your
existing systems more deeply
with Firebase and Firebase Auth.
Now what we just saw
was just one application
of Cloud Functions, and I'm
going to invite Lauren back
to show other cool stuff you
can do with Cloud functions.
LAUREN LONG: Awesome.
Thanks, Hiranya.
So sometimes you
might want to respond
to critical events happening
in our application,
and Cloud Functions is a
great way of doing that.
So the particular event
we want to respond to
is when a user is posting
too many reviews too quickly.
So in other words, they're
spamming the system
and we want a way to ban them.
And you can do that with
the Firebase Admin SDK
integrated inside
of a Cloud Function.
You can prevent future logins
and revoke any existing refresh
tokens.
Now if you've been
paying attention,
you might remember an ID
token lasts for an hour.
So sometimes this could
actually take up to an hour.
What if we want to ban
our user right away?
And that's where
security rules comes in.
So you might remember earlier I
talked about how Firebase uses
security rules to allow granular
access control of database,
and we do this based on the user
ID of a user within Firebase
Authentication.
So here we've got an
example of a security rule
that you can write.
So we have a function
here called isBlackListed
that checks to see
if that user ID is
found in the blacklist
collection in Firestore.
And we then do a match
rule for the collection
where ratings are stored
to see if the user is
in the blacklist.
If the user is in the
blacklist, then they're
not allowed to write a rating.
We then also lock down
control to the blacklist
to make sure nobody
can write to it.
Only a privileged environment
like a Cloud Function
can make changes to a blacklist.
So let's see how all that works.
So here we've got our
Cloud Functions code,
and I'm going to
just scroll down
to our function called
updateActivityIndicators, which
is where all of this happens.
So this is a Firestore
triggered function.
It is triggered on
[? writes ?] to any ratings.
So in other words, when someone
has posted a new rating.
We first get the
user ID, and this we
get from the parameter
within the database path.
We then have a
helper function that
checks this user ID to see
if they've been posting
a lot of reviews in
the last little bit
and see if we should ban them.
So in our demo today, we
are allowing two messages
for every 2 minutes.
And if users are
posting more than that,
then they will be banned.
If shouldBan is
true, we will then
update the user's user object
in Firebase Authentication
to be disabled.
We will also add them to
the blacklist collection
in Firestore.
Remember, this is
the collection we're
checking for in
our security rules
to see if the user is
able to do another rating.
And if we don't end up
needing to ban the user,
we will reward them
for their review
by incrementing their score.
So let's try to see if I
can trigger the blacklist.
So here we've got
some movies and I'm
going to just start
writing some reviews.
So I'm going to write
a review for this one.
A tattooed Interpol agent
sounds like a bad movie.
Sorry if you actually
like this movie,
but I'm going to
write it one star.
Let's see, we've got this one.
It's a cop movie.
I typically like
cop movies, so we'll
rate that a four
star out of five.
So I've now hit my max.
The next one I rate should
trigger the blacklist.
So let's do a review.
So I get this review submitted.
Let's try to do one more.
So now I am banned from
submitting anymore reviews
as you can see from
this error message.
Now that was from the security
rules that we just looked at.
Let's see if I can log
out and log back in.
So I try to log in again.
I see that my account has been
disabled by the administrator.
Can we switch battles
to the slides, please?
So one thing I do
want to note is
you should not be deleting user
accounts as a way to ban them.
And the reason for
that is then they
can just sign up again
and create a new account.
Whereas is if you actually
disable the account,
then that prevents them
from doing further activity.
HIRANYA JAYATHILAKA:
Up until now,
we've been using
the Admin SDKs to do
all our external
integrations, but there
might be times
where you would want
to implement an integration
without an Admin SDK.
Maybe your use
case is very simple
and you feel like taking
a dependency on the SDK
is overkill, or maybe
you are programming
in a language for which the
Admin SDK is not available yet.
Whatever your
reasons are, Firebase
strives to expose its services
via REST whenever possible so
you can access them
overall good old HTTPS.
So as our last demo,
let's look at how
to implement a
simple CLI tool that
interacts with the Firebase
Realtime Database over REST.
Our objective is to
build a Ruby client
for displaying the top 10
most active FireFlicks users.
We don't have an official
Admin SDK for Ruby yet,
so this gives us an
excuse to use REST.
As for tracking the
most active users,
remember that we already
have a workflow implemented
in Cloud Functions that
Lauren demonstrated
earlier which awards users
points for their posts.
So the data we are
looking for is already
stored in Realtime database.
So now we are just going
to implement the lower
part of this diagram, where
our CLI tool securely queries
for the most active users.
And if you're
wondering why we are
using Realtime Database
for this last demo,
it's because the REST
API for Realtime Database
actually supports richer
queries at the moment
than Firestone does.
So all Firebase and GCP
REST APIs support OAuth2,
so we need to include
an OAuth2 bearer token
in all the requests we make.
The easiest way to
do this is by using
one of the official Google
Auth libraries, which
are available in about
seven different programming
languages.
That's what we are going to do.
But if you feel that's
too heavy weight,
you can also code the
OAuth flow yourself.
It's just a standard OAuth flow.
In general, if you [INAUDIBLE]
this account or a refresh token
you can always exchange that
for a valid OAuth2 token.
So let's go to our demo again
and look at our Ruby code.
It's been a while since
I've written any Ruby code.
So the first thing we do is
just require the googleauth Ruby
gem, and then we
have some code here
to just initialize it out using
a Google application default
credentials.
And this is the URL that we are
going to make the REST call on.
It's basically just to direct
URL to the Realtime Database.
And we are requesting it
to order all the users
by their score and
give me the 10 last
or the 10 highest
scores in the database.
And then we basically
have a big loop here
which periodically makes
the same REST API call.
Some code here to actually
apply the authorization header
to the outgoing
request and some code
to parse the JSON response
coming from Realtime Database
and show it in a
nice little CLI view.
So let's quickly try it out.
So here are some
fake data that's
coming from our database.
We wanted to make sure that
your email doesn't accidentally
appear here.
Very famous people
there and Sam Stern
for some reason, who's a
developer for Firebase.
Just to make sure that
it's working as intended,
I'm going to go and just update
some data manually and see
if it gets picked up.
Realtime database.
Right now Steven Spielberg
has 2,000 points.
I'm going to boost his
point by a factor of 10,
and you can see it jumps
up to the top right away.
Let's go back to
our demo slides.
So Realtime Database
is certainly not
the only Firebase product for
which there is a REST API.
In fact, we are increasingly
opening up our products
for RESTful integrations.
This is just a partial list
of what's available today.
And the nice thing is the
way you authorize requests
for all these APIs is identical
to what we demonstrated today.
If you know how to integrate
it with one REST API,
you can pretty much use any of
these other REST APIs as well.
Now we are approaching
the end of our talk.
We've been looking at a
lot of code, a lot of demos
in the last 15 minutes or
so, so it's a good time
to take a step
back and just take
the bird's eye view
of everything we've
developed so far.
We started out with a fairly
straightforward Firebase
app that uses Firebase
Auth and Cloud
Firestore as our database.
Then we implemented a
the little Python script
to create new user
accounts in Firebase Auth
and grant them
the moderator role
by setting some custom claims.
The same script also handles
generating invitation codes
and saving them into a database.
Then we implemented a little
Go App Engine endpoint
that allows users to
log in to FireFlicks
using the invitation codes
they receive over email.
We added a second endpoint
to that same Go application
which receives the ID token
of the caller, verifies it,
and if it's coming
from a moderator,
calls out to another
external API--
Twitter in this case--
to publish some tweets.
Then we implemented a custom
email verification flow using
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
We implemented the
serverless function that gets
triggered every time
a new user signs up.
There we use the
Node.js Admin SDK
to generate email verification
links and send them out.
Then we looked at a
second Cloud Function
that gets triggered for every
movie review posted by a user.
We use it to track
spamming behavior
and potentially ban such
users from the system.
We disable their user
accounts in Firebase Auth
and use Firebase
security rules to cut off
their immediate access
to our database.
And finally, we implemented
little Ruby CLI tool
to securely query our
Realtime database over REST.
Now this is certainly
a lot of moving
parts implemented in several
different-- about four
languages.
Your application architecture
is probably not as complex
or distributed, at
least maybe not yet.
But the point we
are trying to make
is that if you want
to build something
more advanced and
sophisticated using Firebase,
you certainly can.
You can start simple like
we did with just one or two
Firebase services and
then incrementally bring
your existing systems, APIs,
and data into the architecture
and try to stay ahead of
your changing requirements.
You can use things like the
Admin SDK, REST APIs, and Cloud
Functions to bridge
different components
and make sure that you
use the same users, roles,
and data both in Firebase
and everywhere else.
Lauren.
LAUREN LONG: So in
conclusion, Firebase
is a development platform that
allows you to build your apps,
monitor their performance,
and grow your user base.
And we can integrate
with your existing
systems, whether they're on-prem
or with another cloud provider.
And there's two main
ways you do that.
One is by using the
Firebase Admin SDK.
We used that SDK in
several languages today.
And you can also
use the REST APIs,
which you can call within
your server or any server.
And lastly, we also
demonstrated how
you can use Cloud Functions as a
glue between different services
and also as a way to respond
to critical events happening
in your app.
All of our SDKs, including
the Firebase Admin SDKs,
are open source,
so we invite you
to be part of our community,
to file bug reports,
contribute, and give us
your feature requests.
[MUSIC PLAYING]